the practiced eye of a specialist we're
in Switzerland at the radiology
department of Basel University Hospital
radiologist dr. Geiger Zoma is analyzing
tomographic images and will then make a
diagnosis it's stressful work and can
mean a 10-hour day this is the monotony
it's pretty monotonous you do get to
deal with new patients and new problems
all the time but at the end of a long
day you start to lose your focus it's
pasando I'm offices position opening
with a relatively simple case can take
just 10 minutes to analyze more
complicated diagnosis need up to half an
hour the radiologists here in Basel deal
with an estimated 10,000 cases a month
and that number is increasing Donahue
fits a hobby it would be really useful
to have technology that would help us to
identify potential problems in patients
who are looking for hello spheres opens
Oh perhaps an automated device or some
sort of software and student Hudson
doesn't say of course in computer
technology to the rescue brahm status is
in charge of developing innovative
projects at the radiology department
he's working with a local big data
startup company to develop algorithms
that will make the radiologists job
simpler
TV zone is I need us sandy the idea is
to create a system that will spot
problems that the human eye might miss
once even feed me us and we'll train the
specialists to be able to recognize that
data so that they'll be able to provide
diagnosis that are even more effective
generally speaking algorithms can
already spot anomalies in scanned images
and can do it more quickly than humans
can for example the computer has
precisely identified this tumor in just
a matter of seconds these days the scans
must be read individually that takes a
lot of time and effort it would be more
effective if a number of values could be
analyzed at once like with a full blood
test computers could analyze a number of
cases in a fraction of a second and find
any similarities even in cases that date
back years the sannin imbued seat is not
that these are post evaluation images
you can make out healthy tissue and
damaged tissue the healthy tissue is
pink and the tumor tissue is green I can
identify problem areas right away just
by looking at the images of unwinding
boo i can but will this technology make
radiologists redundant
Vermont East a few intercede on that
when you get involved in this kind of
work and this kind of technology its
you'll see that there will continue to
be a place for radiologists wouldn't for
example they'll be able to transfer data
to other branches of the medical
profession that don't have this sort of
expertise in the phone that they exist
skyforce didn't miss me Kevin Millar is
the driving force behind these
technological innovations he understands
how image analysis and adaptive
algorithms work and he's impressed that
the specialists at the hospital in Basel
have welcomed the opportunity to try
something new thus Vic texture forms
bottom on it was really important for us
that they were very welcoming about this
was it the hum kisi and thus timid they
saw that the medical profession is going
to change radically over the next 20
years when she starts they didn't reject
new technology or oppose it hi didn't
they embraced it Hamza gevalt And tile
from diesel bruises I was a veek on mom
they wanted to learn new skills so that
they wouldn't be replaced by computers
of us for Noah and that will open up new
opportunities for them off our land and
the McMartin DS about a hundred I can
come that makes sense because the data
is already there in the images
[Music]
it's the analysis of all that material
that takes a lot of time and effort and
that could be done quickly and
effectively by a computer that will give
doctors more time to focus on clinical
procedures that will benefit their
patients
[Music]